Teams are amazing,
you know,
after the,
um,
the clint would speech Eastwick became a
thing Hashtag [inaudible],
which just means it means that you are
going to entirely.
It means you take a picture of yourself
looking at a chair and there are,
there are,
there are no pictures of dogs online.
This was the day after.
I mean that's,
that's I think also venues have the half
life of like reddit is the place where a
lot of that original,
which is interesting.
It's like the,
what's the deal?
You vote,
you voted up.
It's just an up vote down vote system.
So anyone who has an account,
can you go cast a vote which is like a
thumbs up or down,
which is,
and that's how they aggregate the
reaction and whoever has whatever,
whatever,
no matter what has the most uploads,
it goes to the top of their list.
You think,
you think that's where a lot of the
names,
especially because you look at all of
these content sites with a post or all
of these websites,
buzzfeed or something less feed ton of
them.
Also,
a lot of them youtube clips that can
come that go viral first,
get their big first push on Reddit,
some Weirdo we'll post it to.
It's called subreddits.
More specified topics within reddit.
So there's like,
are you active?
Are you an active redditor?
I look at it every day.
I will contribute and I don't have an
account.
Yeah.
Um,
I'd,
I'd just like to observe.
I look at Buzzfeed,
do buzzfeed.
I do sometimes when I'm feeling not good
as particularly shitty about myself.
There's interesting because it's,
it's the most successful rags slash
highly opinionated.
It is arrived.
It's total rag,
but at the same time they have
interesting things to say.
Sometimes there's this spoiler or
they'll,
they'll promote interesting conversation
sometimes like half of it is,
you know,
who just had tweeted like newt,
like nudes of themselves,
Dick Pics.
And the other side is a civil rights.
Like no,
like being in informing important
political things.
This is why I hate,
by the way,
this is why I hate getting coffee into
the saucer because every time you lift
it up,
it drips onto the paper.
Do this.
Let's see that,
that,
that made it 100 percent,
you know,
drip,
drip.
But now,
now I know that ended that saucer,
this with coffee everywhere.